[Music]
ultra marathon cycling is any event
that's 200 miles or more you ride hard
and you ride long distances
riding together it is
realistically uncomfortable but misery
loves company
[Music]
coolest place on the whole ride is going
to be about 90 degrees i'm ann jerzinski
and i'm john jaczynski john and i will
be married two years tomorrow and we
ride a tandem bicycle together
[Music]
they win ready okay
one
two one tandem bicycle is a bicycle
built for two there are two positions on
a tandem bicycle captain is in the front
steering and braking
the stoker is in the back fueling the
engine
she's the power she's the navigator and
the moral support got a right turn and
.7
[Applause]
i tend to be a little better at the
beginning and end of a ride and
and gets me through my doldrums in the
middle john is
really strong on the flats and the
downhills and i tend to like uphills and
get excited by uphills
about 800 feet of the climbing to go
now we hit the hills
we
have ups and downs with one another on
the bike because we're both pretty
intense after you know being in a saddle
for
12 plus hours you get a little cranky um
and so it's amazing we don't argue more
than we do
in 1984 i did my first bicycle race i
saw this
blonde beauty on the bike warming up and
i just kind of said to myself you know
why can't i be with somebody like that
i didn't know it was saying until many
years later in the fall of 2014
john asked me if i might want to ride in
paris press paris
so we decided to get together and do
some long rides and see how we would do
together on the tandem
i just
fell in love with him immediately
the event we're training for is paris
press paris and that's 750 miles i think
we're about as ready as we can be now we
just need a little luck on our side we
hope to do it without sleeping last time
we did it we did it in uh just under 52
hours this time we hope to do better
than that the start is a little
nerve-wracking if somebody bumps you the
wrong way
damages your bike it could be over
working together keep motivating each
other
it's going to be fun
our wave goes off at 5 15 p.m we'll ride
through that night through the next day
through the next night and then
hopefully
finish
before darkness
the next day
four hours ahead of
second and third tandem
and so that energized us even though
we're tired when we did paris press
repairs four years ago at 58 and uh 51
that was our ages then
out of the 100 tandems that participated
from all over the world we were first by
16 hours feeling good
and only
135 or 140 miles left it's unusual maybe
for us to be going as fast as we are but
we're having a really good year
especially for our aarp ages
[Music]
we live in the honda element with a tent
attached i love the simplicity
of
getting up and
taking care of yourself and being
outdoors
mostly we're going to be living out of
here for the next year or two until we
get to all those events we wanted to do
so far we've weathered the rain and the
mosquitoes and
it's been fun
i know that both of us are doing
whatever we can to keep each other safe
physically and emotionally
as a team
and
as
lovers
it's things i used to dream about you
know being able to share these sort of
things
one more checkpoint
feeling good or you just wanna quit we
feel good no no we don't quit now
finish your thing over that kind of time
frame 750 miles
so many things can go wrong
[Applause]
to finish the event is huge i mean
most people who do it are happy with
that and now it's even better because i
get to do it with my lover my
significant other my soul mate you know
i love physical activity and i love the
outdoors and and so does anne it's so
much better going through life
sharing these things
[Music]